[Musique]
pour écoute moi bien mûri dans sa ce
qu'on a assez d'éléments pour toi pour
que tu puisse plus voir le jour pendant
un bon petit moment mais surtout on sait
que lors du casse n'était pas tout seul
ok
je vois
[Musique]
ce café
je crois pas de café ok
[Musique]
ça te parle s'annonçait cetto et son
fils un petit cigarillos tous les deux
comme des potes histoire il fume pas là
ça me vexe et pas qu'un peu
ce que t'as pas compris mourihno sait
comment contrairement à toi je suis payé
pour être là donc j'ai tout le temps
malade tout autant c'est parce que dès
le planning écrit vous êtes sensé finir
à 18h cherche pas à ça dans son planning
[Musique]
sotuver perds mon temps mourinho est
parti pour quinze ans ferme minimum
ils font prison plus dur est en fait si
j'avais su j'aurais dénoncé mon pote
sauf qu'il sera trop tard
assez pour ça le café et tous voulaient
que je balance mon associé chez bain
après c'était pas super clair quoi c'est
pas dit une fois le mot associé déjà ses
dix cafés je comprend effectivement que
c'était peut-être pas tout à fait bien
non je crois je t'écoute
ok je te connais pas vraiment c'est un
mec super discret il n'a pas un mais des
pseudo tu pourrais nous décrire
je pleurais
[Musique]
envoyez-moi le portraitiste et bien
alors il est blanc 30 ans selon les
cheveux clairsemés l'avait lunettes
rondes et il a une boucle d'oreille
c'est tout il a une cicatrice
il est une grosse cicatrice sur la joue
droite
[Musique]
surtout sera reçue mais merci d'avoir
coopéré me
comment
est-ce que c'est lui non lui
non non mais j'avais dit des lunettes
rondes
non mes jeunes surtout là c'est un vieux
et j'avais dit une cicatrice mais c'est
harry potter non mais la c1 c'est un
paysage le mec tu me c'est même plus des
portraits ce que tu montes la regardez
vous même
on
mais là c'est un paysage lyonnais sait
même plus des portraits ce que vous
regardez vous même
[Musique]
tenez vous en à discussion merci on est
sur le point d'avoir le portrait du
suspect roulait deux hommes
[Musique]
c'est lui les teneurs non
non
rien
à
tu peux tu abonnés à la chaîne
multiprise pour retrouver le méchant la
cicatrice le flic berné par le méchant
la cicatrice le barbu interrogées qui a
fait un coup avec le méchant la
cicatrice on a une chaîne a3 en fait
c'est pour ça et tu peux aussi voir le
making of de cette vidéo dans lequel se
trouve le méchant à l'alluré inquiétante
oui tu pensais que j'allais dire autre
chose peut-être